nach wie vor brennt es in vielen Teilen
Ostdeutschlands die verheerenden
Flächenbrände in Brandenburg und Sachsen
verwüsten ganze Gebiete in der
Grenzregion zwischen Deutschland und
Tschechien ist die Lage besonders
angespannt in der Sächsischen Schweiz
brennen rund 250 Hektar Wald und auf
tschechischer Seite in der Böhmischen
Schweiz stehen unfassbare tausend Hektar
in Flammen während Bewohner aus einigen
Regionen Brandenburgs und Sachsens
evakuiert werden müssen sie immer wieder
rein in die brennenden Wälder sie
kämpfen gegen die Flammen kämpfen gegen
die Hitze und die Müdigkeit bis zur
Erschöpfung vollkommen geschafft
schlafen Feuerwehrmänner nach
stundenlang Einsatz direkt am Wald um
nach einer kurzen Verschnaufpause gleich
wieder reinzugehen hier sehen wir dieses
Bild reinzugehen in den Kampf gegen die
Flammen dabei sind sie teils über 20
Stunden im Dienst ihre
Einsatzbereitschaft ist bewundernswert
sie opfern ihre Freizeit riskieren ihre
eigene Gesundheit mit diesem Mut und
ihrer Entschlossenheit sind sie die
Helden Auslandes Feuerwehrleute
Feuer in Deutschland
Waldbrände in Sachsen
Katastrophenalarm
im Minutentakt nehmen die
Löschhubschrauber der Bundeswehr bei Bad
Schandau Wasser aus der Elbe auf fliegen
immer wieder zu den Brandherden in den
unwegsamen Waldgebieten zwischen
Deutschland und Tschechien
deutsche Einsatzkräfte die zunächst auch
auf tschechischem Gebiet Unterstützung
leisten müssen jetzt auf deutschem Boden
die Lage in den Griff kriegen mehr als
400 Einsatzkräfte kämpfen unermüdlich
gegen das Inferno rund 250 Hektar Wald
stehen in Flammen unaufhaltsam
verschlingt das Feuer alles was ich ihm
in den Weg stellt verwüstet ganze
Landstriche und bedroht Existenzen
im tschechischen Rendsburg fangen die
ersten Wohnhäuser Feuer und brennen
nieder auf tschechischer Seite stehen
fast 1.000 Hektar Fläche in Flammen
bei den lösch Einsätzen auf sächsischen
Boden werden 8 Einsatzkräfte verletzt
auflebende Winde auswechselnden Richtung
treiben die Brände immer wieder in alle
Richtungen vor das Feuer ist nicht zu
bändigen die Löscharbeiten im
zerklüfteten terrar sind besonders
schwierig der Einsatz von
löschhubschraubern der einzige Weg die
Waldbrände unter Kontrolle zu bekommen
deswegen ist es
unheimlich kräftiger aus der Luft bei
den Löscharbeiten unterstützen um diese
Feuer diese verlierenden Brände so
schnell wie möglich wieder in den Griff
zu bekommen auch wenn zwischendurch
Einsetzen der Regen die Brände teilweise
entschärft ist die Lage weiterhin ernst
so muss laut den Behörden unbedingt
verhindert werden dass sich die
verschiedenen Brandherde zu einer
Feuerwand zusammenschließen dennoch
Menschen leben sehen die
Verantwortlichen derzeit noch nicht in
Gefahr allerdings ist es so dass wir
keine Anwohner
evakuieren müssen wir mussten auch
bisher keine Wohngebiete evakuieren und
auch andere mussten wir nicht aus dem
Gebiet evakuieren Feuer bei uns in
Deutschland
Waldbrände im Osten Sachsens und ein
Ende ist noch nicht in Sicht
unsere porterin Klara Marie Becker ist
in schmilker im Landkreis Sächsische
Schweiz Ost-Erzgebirge direkt an der
deutsch-tschechischen Grenze guten
Morgen Clara wie ist die Situation heute
früh
ja die Situation heute morgen ist so
dass ich über Nacht die Brände hier wohl
verschlimmert haben gestern haben wir
gesehen oder von oben sogar gesehen und
auch gehört es gab gestern fünf
brennschwerpunkte 200 Kräfte waren hier
im Einsatz auf deutscher Seite jetzt ist
es wohl so dass im nördlich der Grenze
wieder neue Feuer ausgebrochen sind die
jetzt auch heute im Laufe des Tages mit
Hilfe der Hubschrauber von Bundespolizei
und Bundeswehr gelöscht werden sollen
die allerdings bis jetzt noch nicht
fliegen konnten denn es war heute morgen
erstmal muss es natürlich hell werden
und dann war es heute morgen auch sehr
sehr nebelig hier vor Ort deswegen
können die Helikopter jetzt demnächst
erst starten und dann bei den
Löscharbeiten unterstützen hier hinter
mir sieht man die Feuerwehrmänner und
die Einsatzkräfte vom THW die sich jetzt
hier bereit machen im Laufe des Tages
sollen die Kräfte weiter aufgestockt
werden aktuell sind 275 Kräfte im
Einsatz und genau im Laufe des Tages
werden es eben noch mehr werden und ja
hier macht man sich natürlich auch
fertig für den neuen Einsatz es wird
durch rotiert die Kräfte die heute Nacht
unterwegs waren müssen abgelöst werden
und die ja die Einsatzkräfte können sich
hier ein bisschen erholen kurz zur Ruhe
kommen etwas trinken etwas essen denn
sie haben ja auch wirklich heftige
Stunden hinter sich
vielen Dank Clara Marie Becker für diese
ganz aktuellen ein
[Musik]
drücke